that is definitely a baby bump first
question why did you hide your pregnancy
all this time
so how to take care of skin to avoid
stretch marks do you ever worry about
your child's nutrition in the womb while
being a meat eater did you change your
mind about getting a surrogate how long
was labor for your first kiddo was it
super painful labor was weirdly quick
and I would like to credit hypn birthing
which sounds like the most hippie
thing anger and resentment towards
partner in first trimester do doctors
get mad at your diet while pregnant some
would but like screw those guys what are
your plans for postpartum rest are you
eating organ meat now for the baby what
are some things a new husband can do to
help his wife during our first pregnancy
I hate when couples say we're pregnant
one of you is pregnant are you working
out or how are you staying the same size
except the baby
bump I'll tell you guys what I'm doing
hey guys welcome to my podcast this is a
pregnancy Q&A take a look at
this that is definitely a baby bump I'm
officially 35
weeks and I'm going to run through a
bunch of questions that you guys had
kind of update you about why I didn't
tell anybody and what it's been like and
how everything is going what my diet is
like Etc so let's Jump Right In first
question how phenomenal is your baby
daddy he's pretty
phenomenal why did you hide your
pregnancy all this time
so that's a bit of a long story uh I
would say probably the main reason I
hate hit it is because I wasn't sure if
it was going to keep that was part of it
I wasn't sure if it was going to keep um
two I don't think pregnant women are
taken seriously by anybody I don't even
think I take pregnant women seriously
and I'm running a number of businesses
too many I'll get into that too and
negotiating with people talking to
lawyers talking to other business people
is already difficult enough I'm
already difficult to take Serious I
think because of how I look in my blonde
hair Etc so add a pregnant belly on top
of that and you get someone who is not
taking seriously at all and so I didn't
want people to judge me so that was part
of it um as for the not
taking last year August 2022 I had a
miscarriage it was called a blighted
ovam and apparently it's quite common I
had no idea what that was like I'd never
heard of it before it wasn't a great
experience uh I got pregnant I was 8
weeks pregnant and I went from my first
ultrasound I think it might have been
nine weeks I went for my first
ultrasound and Jordan and I got there
and they're doing the ultrasound and
they get to the uterus and there
is no baby it's just an empty
sack
and
I
was like what on Earth is this evil
thing that I'm seeing because I didn't
even know that that was possible so what
happens with blighted oams is your body
miscarries at some point and then your
body also continues to act as if it's
pregnant so your uterus expands a little
bit you're still flooded with all the
hormones you have all the symptoms of
pregnancy and there's no no embryo and
then there's no fetus it's messed up and
after I went through that I talked to
some family members and it turns out
that this is fairly common for people
who've had multiple babies and for women
to experience and it's pretty horrifying
so you guys should know about it in case
it happens to you it does seem to be
weirdly common miscarriages are actually
really unfortunately common and they're
extremely unpleasant but but you're not
alone if you're experiencing one or have
experienced them I had a really hard
time with that pregnancy as soon as I
got pregnant I felt like I was going
insane I was having suicidal thoughts
and you know people who suffer from
depression kind some can get intrusive
thoughts and so I was having these
intrusive thoughts that I haven't really
had on the carnivore diet which was just
like violent intrusive thoughts very
unpleasant I felt very isolated and
alone even though though there wasn't
anything in my relationship that should
have been making me feel that way it was
purely hormonal and I had a miserable
time and I can remember praying like God
make make this stop I can't handle it
and then at about 8 weeks pregnant I
started to feel a little bit more normal
and then in N9 weeks we went for an
ultrasound and like boom no baby so I
don't know if I went like crazy because
there was actually something wrong and
it was my body saying like
something's wrong but um eh wasn't a
great experience wasn't a great
experience so that happened so this time
when I got
pregnant I didn't go
crazy and so I didn't believe I was
pregnant so I had these pregnancy tests
and I was like there's no way and Jordan
was like there's no way and we kept
having these positive pregnancy tests I
was like there's I don't feel anything
there's no way but we went to get an
ultrasound super early at like 6 weeks
instead of waiting which I'm never going
to wait again because of the blighted
ovam thing that can happen and there was
a heartbeat everything's going smoothly
and then um I was as you guys know I was
in between houses you might say because
we'd found black mold among other molds
and bacterias in the water damaged house
I was living in in Miami and so we were
in living in hotels I didn't have a
studio set up um one of these questions
somewhere I'll pull it up but
was did you take time off because you
were pregnant cuz I told people it was
because I was like sick from mold I
didn't actually take time off at the
beginning when I was pregnant it was cuz
I was sick from mold I didn't feel
pregnant for a really long time and I
lost quite a bit of weight in the mold
house and I when I call it a mold house
it wasn't a mold house you couldn't see
mold it was a really nice house uh it
was in the AGA and behind the drywall
and there was no super clean we kept
things super clean there was no evidence
of
mold until the very end when I started
to see it in one spot behind the Paint
was like that's what's screwing me up um
but yeah I didn't take time off at the
beginning because I didn't feel pregnant
but what did happen pretty early on is I
got a me version so we'll keep going
we'll keep
going for some new questions and I'll
cover that soon hey guys one of you
asked whether or not you can sauna while
pregnant I was saing while pregnant and
then I had to stop near the third
trimester because my body couldn't
handle it but I am so looking forward to
using one of these guys again it's going
to be one of the first things I do after
I give birth because I miss it so much
Bond charge sauna blankets would be a
sweet gift for anyone and they're so
handy these blankets work just like
traditional saing they help you break a
sweat burn coward reduce inflammation
setting it up is super easy taking less
than a minute the benefits for me
include a mood boost reduction in brain
fog if I'm having any brain fog having a
lot of brain fog with pregnancy
reduction in anxiety relaxed but I have
more energy I love them Bond charge
ships worldwide offers a hassle-free
30-day trial and has free shipping as
well if you're looking for a great
Christmas gift consider the gift of
Wellness with Bond charges in for on a
blanket head over to bond charge.com
that's b o n c h r g.com and I've linked
it in the comments
slmp and use code MP for 15% off enjoy
the rest of this
episode what are some things a new
husband can do to help his wife during
our first pregnancy that is a super cute
question I hate when when couples say
we're
pregnant that's like a pet peeve I have
because you guys are both not pregnant
one of you is pregnant and one of you is
feeling it and the other one is not
feeling it however that's a very cute
question and I would just
say have as much patience as you can
because your wife is going to be such a
hormonal disaster at some point if not
right away that she needs somebody there
who's stable and calm and can kind of
listen to her neurotic thoughts and this
goes for like my husband and my neurotic
thoughts normally I don't worry about
things unless they're really really
serious and normally I don't cry very
much I think I cry way less than the
average woman like way less and normally
I'm doing pretty good uh but the
hormones you get when you're pregnant
are insane so now that I'm 35 weeks I've
been crying every day 100% like this
morning I cried just cuz I was sad why
am I sad I've probably been sad for the
entire third
trimester just like sad a little
detached kind of feels like an alien
took over my brain I don't have much of
an internal dialogue it's a lot harder
to work and hormones are crazy right now
like I've got six times as much estrogen
and I believe progesterone as normal no
one's taking those for fun like hey you
want some extra progesterone by this
much nobody wants that so I would say
for taking care of your wife just listen
to her neurotic concerns about the house
or work listen tell her you're going to
help her through it and don't argue like
you would normally argue like if you're
normally good at negotiating things out
and really getting into it just kind of
take it easy
because your wife is a hormonal mess and
she's growing another human and it
is
hard it's hard um kudos to like any mom
out there because it's hard and I know
some people enjoy pregnancy and some
people really don't I'm not a person who
does um but what I will say is this
pregnancy as much as I'm having a harder
time now near the end and as difficult
as aspects were it could have been so
much worse and so I'm really thankful
for that because when I had Scarlet that
would have been 7 years ago now it was
really really hard and all my autoimmune
symptoms came back and I was miserably
depressed and there are multiple reasons
for that
but this is nothing like that thank
goodness however near the
end it's been it's a hole it's a
thing okay
next are you still working and will this
change things for for your dad's
company's PS
congratulations this will change nothing
my plan for pregnancy was to just work
the whole time
cuz I get so much dopamine from
accomplishing things and from moving
forward towards goals that that's what I
like to do and I was like well I don't
really want to take Matt leave I'm not
taking Matt leave maybe I'll have to and
I tried to figure out ways to set it up
if I slowed down but then about 3 weeks
ago so around 32 weeks my body was just
like you're joking you're kidding
yourself um and so I've been spending a
lot more time like napping and in bed I
got a wicked flu so I was sick for like
3 weeks I've had a headache off and on
for the last eight days that's been
pretty bad like enough to stop me from
being able to see very well and so
nothing's changing with my dad's
companies and with with Peterson Academy
everything's moving forward uh and I'm
still working but I've
definitely tried to identify the main
goals that we need to accomplish and
just focus on that and I've tried to
limit my
perfectionism so normally if I see
something that's a little bit off I'm
like ah fix it it's got to be at this
level and now I'm thinking okay maybe
we'll keep it at this level a little bit
lower no one's going to notice you know
not everything has to be perfect uh that
being said that's not a comment on
Peterson Academy cuz that's going
perfectly but to give you guys an
example like we've been working on
perfecting the courses that are going
the going to go on the platform and the
courses are the content's unbelievably
good but I also wanted to make them
catchy because like I'm not even
somebody who listens to podcast or watch
his video content normally I just
read otherwise I get distracted I don't
know if you'd call it add but we're
going to call it
add uh for now I don't think it
qualifies as that but I need some
stimulation during video content
otherwise I start thinking about other
things so I was like I want to make
these courses visually stimulating and
better than anything else we've seen and
so Jordan and I have been like working
with our production team and working
with the editors and going back and
forth and back and forth and back and
forth and they are looking sweet I
haven't seen
course content that's actually
stimulating before so we're already at
that level and I want to get this thing
out there we had to delay our launch was
supposed to be in
November and we had to delay
because this is such a huge
project um which I vastly
underestimated uh it's such a huge
project now we're looking for at a
launch of um late January
and it's going swimmingly so things are
going well but I have had to limit the
amount I can accomplish to more
reasonable goals like I'm the type of
person that likes setting really stupid
large goals and then giving myself time
frames that are not
achievable just to like add some stress
to do things faster and I've had to dial
that in so that's a long-winded answer
to will things ch but no I'm still
overseeing things Jordan's overseeing
things with me now and we have teams in
place that are amazing things are still
moving forward as planned and I do plan
on slowing down in
January I'm due January 7th that's
key right after my birthday my
birthday's on the
4th
so yeah like with the sleep deprivation
from breastfeeding CU you breastfeed
every 3 hours at the beginning um I'm
I'm going to I'm just forced to take
things slower fortunately I work from
home so I can still get things done but
it is a little bit stressful I don't
really like taking time away but it's a
baby so it's not really time away right
um another big thing what am I having I
like talking about Peter and Academy
more than the baby which is ridiculous
but I'm having a
boy which is so exciting cuz I've got a
little girl Scarlet she's six and I
don't have a boy so we're going to have
a little boy January
7th okay
next o so just to cover the mold thing
and then hopefully we don't cover the
mold thing anymore how soon after the
mold exposure did you get pregnant was
your body cleansed so I told you guys
before I got sick enough in that stupid
house that I was having trouble walking
upstairs and I thought it was kind of
funny I wasn't freaking out about it but
I was like H going halfway up the stairs
and being like I can't need a breather
and then I'd like chuckle about it and
at a certain point I was like oh no this
is not worth laughing about this is
actually serious and so we moved out of
the house literally 8 weeks later I got
pregnant and that's
after almost 2 years
of kind of trying and a miscarriage so
it was like as soon as the mold as soon
as I was out of that house I got
pregnant which was crazy I did not
expect to get pregnant that fast because
I checked my before I found out it was
mold i' done a ton of blood work looking
at any possible reason why I was sick
cuz I've been so dialed in with my diet
that it was like why am I suddenly sick
again and I looked at my hormones and my
hormones were like premenopausal
flat and I found that out at the same
time as we figured out it was mold so I
was like oh okay mold was causing it I'm
sure they'll recover but they recovered
quickly obviously otherwise I wouldn't
have been able to get pregnant like 8
weeks no I wasn't fully recovered from
the mold exposure by any means it was
kind of like oh now I'm going to have to
do the recovery and be pregnant at the
same time that sounds like a little
rough but anyway it worked out I wasn't
fully recovered but I was able to walk
upstairs without getting out of breath
my eyes weren't red anymore I wasn't
congested anymore I started to have more
positive emotion my internal dialogue
came back so I was feeling quite a bit
better just eight weeks out of that
house um also taking a binder called
colestyramine
so yeah very soon after mold exposure I
got pregnant but I I got out of that
house as a working mom thoughts on
studies on negative effects of Early
Child Care no hate okay this is a great
question there are a lot of studies on
early daycare having negative outcomes
for your kid in pretty nasty ways so uh
I'll tell you guys what I'm doing and
then I can tell you my opinions but what
I'm doing is I'm getting a newborn care
specialist uh for for night times so
I'll be breastfeeding at night anyway
but I'll have somebody there who can
kind of bring me the baby I'll
breastfeed and then they can take the
baby back calm them down put them back
to sleep I've got such a difficult time
I have such a difficult time getting to
sleep that if I didn't have help in that
way I wouldn't sleep and if I didn't
sleep like that I wouldn't be able to
continue with all these projects that
I'm doing that I want to continue with
so I really need to focus on getting as
much sleep as I can so we have a newborn
care specialist helping and I'm going
going to have a nanny as well so that's
two people helping me and thank God I
can afford that at this point because
with Scarlet I didn't have anybody
and it was really hard I started
working pretty quickly after I had
Scarlet but when she was 6 months I was
full-time working but I had like the
baby on me at home and I was working um
so I never did daycare and part of the
reason for that was
because I was fortunate enough have to
be able to afford help so with Scarlet I
got a
nanny um when she was 11 months old and
I was still working from home so I was
still able to breastfeed but it was
somebody there that could watch her
while I was
working
and that's what I I could barely afford
that like that took almost all my money
but uh
that I think that that if that's
something you can do I think that that's
a better idea than doing daycare when
kids are really
young
uh let me
think that's my opinion and then there's
also a realm of daycares you can look
into like sometimes daycare is your
neighbor who brings over three or four
kids and then she's taking care of three
or four kids in this really homey
environment that's different than than
like 14 kids to daycare resentful
daycare workers that don't care about
your kids and I think that's where
things get iffy and then I would say if
you are going to put your kids in dayare
you can also judge how it's going like
are you dropping off your kid and
they're
screaming like screaming and are they
screaming and it's been two weeks and
they're still screaming when you drop
them off probably that's not a great
sign right now maybe they're three and a
half and you have them in daycare and
they're just going Bye Mom see you later
I don't think those are the kids that
end up with problems so just as a parent
you need
to judge that and be aware of that and
try to set up something that doesn't
traumatize your kids that's important so
for me I felt like that was getting
extra help while I was at home and I was
like I said fortunate enough that I
barely could afford that but I could was
scarlet and now I can afford more help
thank
goodness so yeah I think you have to be
aware of the negative effects of daycare
on kids
and make sure you don't traumatize your
kid right and I do think that the excuse
of like well well that's what I can
afford like I need
to drop them off at this cheaper daycare
where there's 14 kids when they're 8
months
old maybe figure out something
else cuz you don't want your kid having
trauma forever so maybe don't do that
like figure out something else and I
really don't believe that people in
general don't have options like you do
have options you're just not willing to
pursue those options I also don't think
that you should feel guilty though about
getting help and I felt really bad even
when Scarlet was 11 months old and I got
a nanny she was either 10 months or 11
months old or like got a nanny and I
felt bad getting a nanny uh because my
mom was a stay-at home mom and didn't
have help
and I thought that made me a bad mom and
I don't think that anymore at all I
think that you need to do whatever puts
you in a place where you're not
resentful and you're taking care of
yourself so that you can take care of
your kid cuz a resentful parent
especially a resentful parent towards
their child is one of the most toxic
things that can happen to a kid
so really try and plan out your life and
figure out how to make this possible for
you and it shouldn't be something that
breaks down your relationship or
traumatizes your
kid
there apologies if that wasn't as smooth
as it should have been I'm I have no
internal dialogue because my baby ate my
brain okay
next did you change your mind about
getting a
surrogate Okay so
I did I didn't talk about this either
but I did egg
harvesting about a year
ago just less than a year ago because
I'd had this miscarriage and I wasn't
getting pregnant not that we were like
really really trying but we were trying
enough and
I'm 31 and I was like I don't want to be
stupid and miss out on kids so I'm going
to do egg harvesting and so I did
that
thinking I might go the surrogacy route
and I talked to you guys about that
because I was also really worried about
serious mental issues and like dangerous
suicidal mental issues during pregnancy
um so have I changed my mind well I mean
I'm having a
baby um am I going to pursue surrogacy
in the future
possibly
because it's still pretty
hard on me
and I don't want to like I want to be
careful with it because like I said this
could be much much much more difficult
but it's quite difficult um I think I
mentioned I've been sick for the last 3
weeks I've been in bed quite a bit and
I've had like a near migraine for about
8 days and I know I'm near the end but
what's made it more difficult is I'm
still on the lion diet
and I've had a meat aversion the whole
time and so Ive actually lost weight
during the pregnancy because the meat
aversion was so bad I tried to
incorporate other Foods so just starting
with like chicken and honey and those
gave me autoimmune symptoms and the
autoimmune symptoms are more intolerable
than the meat aversion so I had to pull
back from that so it was kind of like a
force myself to eat and probably don't
eat as much as I need to eat eat now
fortunately when you have a baby the
baby just takes from you
so it takes your vitamins it like it
just it just takes everything to grow so
the baby's fine
he's like growing just as he should but
I can tell that I haven't gained as much
weight as I should um for instance all
my rings are loose which normally your
rings don't fit as well especially near
the end of pregnancy so I really have
haven't gained any extra weight which is
like a blessing and a curse cuz hey I'm
not going to have anything to lose but
the reason part of the reason at least
that I'm haven't gained as much as I
would have liked to is because of the
meat aversion on an all meat
diet yeah so that's the answer to the
that question I'm not working out I
haven't actually recovered from the mold
exposure to the point of having enough
energy to work
out
uh I tried to do squats about 2 months
ago and was sore for about 3 weeks which
is just like an abnormal inflammatory
response to exercise it's not cuz I
haven't been exercising and then you get
extra sore I know what that's like it's
an actual inflammatory response so it's
so like sore because I was growing
muscles it was just sore cuz I'm full of
cyto kindes from having an inflammatory
response to exercise so I'm not
recovered enough to do
exercise I'm just skinny because I have
a meat aversion and I'm on a meat diet
that being said I definitely credit the
diet and keeping my autoimmune symptoms
under control for not being completely
nuts during this
pregnancy and making sure my environment
is clean next okay a ton of people asked
about giving birth and the birth plan so
I'm going to cover that so with Scarlet
I gave birth at home and that was partly
because I had a hospital phobia at that
point in my life and that was after I
figured out that diet was causing most
of my issues and that I could control my
issues through diet and that manifested
and turned into a hospital phobia so
anytime I went into a hospital I would
have a panic attack and I was like this
is not ideal you know I'd be totally
fine i' get in a hospital i' be
like having a panic attack and I talk to
my dad about it and he goes well given
what you went through that's a complete
normal response I was like well that
doesn't help the panic attacks in
hospitals like what if I have to go to
the hospital during the pregnancy anyway
I didn't manage to get that phobia under
control during Scarlet's pregnancy so I
gave birth at home and it went it was
really
smooth so I've already done it once so
obviously I'm planning on doing it
again um I have midwives instead of
doctors The Midwives are amazing and I'm
going to give birth at a tub at home
assuming everything goes well if there's
some sort of sign that things aren't
going well then I'll transfer to a
hospital but I don't think that's going
to happen fingers crossed here's another
question how long was labor for your
first Kido was it super painful and did
you get an epidural I didn't get an
epidural cuz I was at home labor was
weirdly quick and I would like to credit
luck but also some preparation I did
hypn birthing which sounds like the most
hippie
thing I don't even like talking about it
because it just it sounds so out there
but I spent about six weeks learning how
to calm my body down because I was
really depressed with Scarlet during
that pregnancy and I was like got to
keep my cortisol low and the reason you
have to keep your cortisol low is
because
when you go into labor your oxytocin
spikes and that starts giving you
contractions and oxytocin will go up and
your contractions will go up and that's
what puts you into labor if your
cortisol spikes it directly counteracts
the
oxytocin so part of the reason I didn't
want to go to a hospital because was
because I knew that if my cortisol
spiked my oxytocin would lower that
would extend the contractions and if the
contractions are too slow and you're in
the hospital they like to give you
something called toin which is similar
to
oxytocin but it's not exactly the same
and if you give a woman pin her
contractions are more intense and
they're more painful and that leads to
epidurals and then epidurals and painful
contractions and an extended labor can
lead to something like a C-section and I
really wanted to avoid a C-section
because who knows what role that played
in my
autoimmunity with not passing on the
proper microbiome right at
Birth
so how long was the
labor it was really easy with Scarlet
from like it started around 11:00 a.m.
till like 8:00 p.m. it was just kind of
it feels like a muscle like 30% of a
muscle cramp you know how painful muscle
cramps can get it was it just feels like
your uterus is just like tightening and
letting go and tightening and letting go
so I wouldn't really call it painful it
was just kind of interesting I was like
well this isn't so bad and then it
started ramping up around 900 p.m. and
by 11:00 p.m. was like okay this is
getting real like this is painful but it
only got the whole labor only got to
about an eight out of 10 on the Pain
Scale that might have been a bit skewed
because at the time my ankle replacement
from having an ankle
replacement uh from
arthritis was installed crooked and was
causing me chronic pain so I was already
used to being in chronic pain so having
a baby didn't feel like it didn't feel
wrong like a badly placed ankle
replacement
so the nice thing about not getting pin
and not having these abnormally strong
contractions is you get a break in
between the contractions so even when
you get to active labor and it's really
intense it kind of goes like eight and
then it stays at an eight but then then
you have like a little bit of time to
catch your breath before another one
hits it's not just like constant
pain um an active labor for me lasted 3
hours and The Midwives who were totally
useless for my first baby one of The
Midwives missed it because she was like
you're a firsttime mom you're going to
have a really long
labor I was like the baby's coming and
she was like no it's not and so she
missed
it uh but I didn't want her there anyway
really so it was was fine my mom was
there and another Midwife now when you
go the Midwife route instead of the
doctor route you get two midwives that
uh come to your
birth so it wasn't that long for the
first kid and theoretically it's
supposed to be shorter for your second
kid although it's been so long we'll see
what happens but I'm expecting a Snappy
labor so we'll see what happens um and I
wouldn't call it super painful it got to
an eight and it was very intense at the
end and but it wasn't something that uh
was traumatizing
or well it wasn't something that was
traumatizing and I think if you oh and
then back over to Hypno birthing hypn
birthing is just this technique that
teaches you how to stay calm and I
really do believe that if you can stay
calm and keep your cortisol low your
body just does birth like you don't have
to learn how to do it it just does it
it's kind of like throwing up not like
you don't have to learn how to throw up
um like a nasty comparison but it's kind
of like that so I would just say
suggestions for like other women you
don't have to do a home birth I would do
a birth wherever you feel calist so if
you feel calist in a hospital and you
think okay I'm taken care of by all
these doctors I can get an epidural if I
need one and you're going to be in your
Zone in there do that right if you're
going to try and force a home birth and
you're going to stress out cuz you're
worried about it that just just
counteracts the purpose of a home birth
so just go where you feel safest and
give birth there like a dog giving birth
under a porch that's kind of like where
I'd like to spend the
next what five weeks maybe less is just
I just want to go to a cave
just talk to me in like six weeks I'll
arrive out of the cave with a baby
everything will be fine leave me in a
cave for the next month oh how to take
care of skin to avoid stretch marks
these are one of those things that I
think is genetic I don't have stretch
marks thank goodness I'm so happy about
that I don't even credit diet for not
giving me stretch marks I actually think
some people are just more prone to
stretch marks and that that's a genetic
thing could be way way off uh so I don't
know much about like creams or anything
that help all I know is I don't get
them but my mom never got them either
and she wasn't on any fancy diet
so that's my answer to that I think it's
genetic that being said not gaining
excess weight during pregnancy obviously
helps your skin stretch less and I'm all
for doing carnivore or animal based or
paleo or keto during pregnancy I think
if you have a caregiver that's like yeah
eat more carbs or like follow your
Cravings then you should get a new
caregiver doctor person now we're going
to go to the diet section tons of people
asked like what's my diet like during
pregnancy because I normally only eat
meat and like I said I'm still only
eating meat would I recommend it for
pregnancy I would recommend you do the
diet that makes you feel the best during
pregnancy so unfortunately for me that
is still the lion diet I can't
incorporate other food Foods if I could
eat anything else without getting
autoimmune flareups and by an autoimmune
flare up I mean arthritis my skin breaks
out which I hate badly uh and I go crazy
I get super volatile I can't think I get
brain foggy I get anxious I just want to
hide in bed if that didn't happen when I
ate other Foods I would 100% be eating
other Foods in general but especially
during pregnancy the number of times
I've cried over not being able to eat a
cucumber during this pregnancy is at
least I would say that's happened at
least 15 times uh because of the meat
aversion during the first
trimester all I wanted was like
cucumbers and it you know people should
be able to eat cucumbers without getting
autoimmune symptoms which I still think
is cuz I was living in mold for most of
my life but time will tell for that but
I would say do the diet that makes you
feel the best don't just give into your
random cravings for bad foods cuz that
does impact your health and it does
impact the health of your baby so you
shouldn't just be loading up on carbs
and gaining excess weight and not caring
about your body um but by no means do I
think that you should be only eating
beef like me it doesn't even feel like
that's what I should be
doing uh right
like the fact that I wanted to cucumber
so badly it's just like it's just some
vegetables like it's not that big a deal
but alas I can't do that yet so anyway
yes I've done carnivore throughout the
pregnancy it has been difficult I don't
know very many pregnant women that
actually stuck to a very strict
carnivore diet throughout pregnancy most
people add in at least a variety of
meats um and dairy
eggs and then a lot of people are like
well I couldn't even do that cuz I had a
meat of ver ver I went back to like a
paleo diet I think that makes sense but
I couldn't do it which has made this
difficult any food or supplement you
recommend for pregnancy I think on any
restricted diet and and any diet it's
the standard American diet for sure you
should be monitoring your vitamins I've
I know now that your vitamin levels
aren't just from what you eat they're
also from your environment my vitamin
levels were totally fine for like 5
years and then I moved into this
particularly moldy house that made me
really sick and a whole bunch of them
plummeted this was right before I got
pregnant so fortunately I had started
supplementing the really deficient
vitamins prior to pregnancy so fate for
example I was taking by injection I'll
link the injection below if you guys
want to inject fite I couldn't take the
or oral version because it gave me
insomnia for who knows like why for
whatever is wrong with my body so I
injected it got my levels back up to
normal and then that was about eight
weeks after we moved out of mold and
that's when I got pregnant so I would
suggest monitoring your vitamins and
supplementing whatever's
low and looking at FID specifically
because at the very beginning FID is
important for the uh baby are you eating
organ meat now for the baby hell no okay
this dies hard enough with a meat of
version I don't like organs the
idea the idea of
liver is so
nauseating no I'm not eating organs I
still don't really believe the whole
organ thing I think if you're on a
regular diet and you incorporate organs
in you can get some benefits but I think
if you're only eating meat I don't I
don't I haven't seen any definitive
evidence of adding in organs and getting
some sort of benefit so I'm not not
doing it I also think it's weird to
desiccate something that you don't even
want to swallow and then force yourself
to take it by pill if your body is like
trying to make you spit it out so that's
still my opinion no I'm not eating
organs having any issues with blood
sugars during pregnancy on Carnivore so
they get you so when you have a midwife
they pretty much follow what an OBGYN
would do although they explain like what
certain blood tests are for and they let
you opt into things but did keep an eye
on my blood sugar for like a week just
to see it is very difficult to get G
gestational diabetes if you only eat
meat if you're not having any carbs not
that any mainstream doctor would admit
to that but how do you get high blood
sugar when you'll need meat so no my
blood sugar has been about 83 to 87 for
the entire
pregnancy uh and I have been in ketosis
the whole time do doctors get mad at you
your diet while pregnant some would but
like screw those guys the the world is
made up
of people who say they know what they're
talking about and don't most people so
if you get a doctor that's like well you
can't do that for all these
reasons do what makes your body the
healthiest be smart like monitor your
vitamins make sure you're not getting a
deficiency of some sort oh if a doctor's
getting mad at you too get a new doctor
I haven't even talked to a doctor have I
talked to a doctor throughout this whole
pregnancy no for the first ultrasound I
was in Dubai and so then a doctor was
like an ultrasound technician did the
ultrasound and then the doctor was like
yes that's a baby that's the only doctor
I've talked
to and it's going to stay that way
assuming everything goes well do you
ever worry about your child's nutrition
in the womb while being a meat eater no
I mean I've had like when I was when I
had Scarlet I was
eating salad and
meat and I had so many people freaking
out about me only eating salad and meat
freaking out it was really stressful
um my family wasn't freaking out but
everybody other than my parents were was
freaking out even though I was just
trying to keep my arthritis under
control was like those foods give me
arthritis that can't be good for the
baby
so do I worry about the child's
nutrition no because babies will take
what they need from you so if you're so
deficient in a vitamin that the baby
can't even take that vitamin from you
that's when you get a problem so keep an
eye on your vitamins my vitamins are
good I have been supplementing fall
light just in case um so no I'm not
worried about that at all I think that
it's I think the diet I'm on is
healthier than what most people eat so
even though I'd like to expand it and I
think it would be better I I don't even
know where I stand with that exactly I
would really like a cucumber so I feel
like I should have be able to eat a
cucumber if I really want one but um my
body doesn't like it yet so we're going
to wait on
that I am still using electrolytes I
don't use them very often but I take
electrolytes sometimes but I'm really
just eating beef so like right now
because the meav verion is still here
and unpleasant I'm eating a lot of TR
tip for some reason tri tip isn't as
nauseating as like aged steak lamb is
completely off a table lamb is oh I
don't know what I'd rather eat liver or
lamb but they're both pretty low on the
list so Lamb's gone that was way too
hard uh fish tasted bad didn't make me
feel very good even chicken kind of
tasted like fish everything's just
tasting like fish in a bad way or
blueberries like I've gone out for steak
and I've been like why is this steak
tastes like blueberries and Jordan's
like what are you talking about like G
meat aversion this is so I'm eating TR
tip and like here's my sexy bag of
jerky I love jerky but I don't really
love jerky pregnant but I'm eating it I
still need to
eat so diet's the
same I took fall light as like a
prenatal and throughout pregnancy by
injection and yes I still include
electrolytes I haven't changed other
than that although I did try to because
the metav verion was so bad and it
didn't go
well okay hey we're doing this let's see
what else oh okay this is this is a good
one anger and resentment towards partner
in first trimester so I would say try
anger and resentment towards your
partner throughout the entire pregnancy
uh I think that's really normal so how
do you counteract that
because
so for like my instance I wanted a baby
I love kids and I want more kids and I
wanted a baby and we were both trying to
have a baby so why would I get resentful
during pregnancy to somebody who gave me
a
baby you can you do I have now I avoid
resentment by communic like overc
communicating everything so if I'm ever
annoyed about something I don't keep it
in my head at all and the reason I know
that is because I used to do that and
that's what breeds resentment so if
you're worried about something even if
it's stupid even if it sounds stupid to
you I would say something like you know
babe you I'm extremely hormonal right
now and I'm really worried about
X and I might be overly worried about it
but I really need help getting through
this cuz I can't handle it by myself so
we need to talk about it and figure out
a plan and then you as the man
instead of
saying getting
irritated or being like that doesn't
matter stop worrying about
it even if it doesn't matter and she
should stop worrying about it talk her
through it here are the potential
Solutions here's what we could do about
it does any of that make you feel
better if you guys can keep open
communication then you can avoid the
anger and resentment now there's still
going to be some anger so I don't have a
resentment problem but I've been so
angry especially third trimester like my
volatility is normally I'm not volatile
I'm very volatile right now I'm like
yell when I get frustrated about
something and part of that is because
Jordan's so
stubborn like he he's a formidable
partner
but it's cuz I'm extremely volatile and
I'm being volatile about things I
wouldn't normally care about which he
can't understand cuz he's not flooded
with six times the amount of hormones he
normally has uh so you have to just keep
Communication open try not to hide
thoughts in your head because they don't
just go away you don't just bury them
and they go
away right they
just destroy your life and breed
resentment so just keep Communication
open and before you have a baby TR try
to make sure your partner is on board
with walking you through things you're
going to be angry and stressed out
about
because pregnant women are
crazy they're crazy especially near the
end I'm crazy right now it's really
annoying I don't really like having
little alien take over my brain it's
frustrating I'd like to think about
things like I normally think about them
or think about things logically without
having this
overwhelming compassion for everything
that I wouldn't normally care about it's
really frustrating experience ideally
your partner can help walk you through
ways to fix whatever you're freaking out
about and not just belittle you for
being an anxious
mess did you co sleep with scarlet and
won't you or will you for this baby I
did Co sleep with Scarlet because I was
breastfeeding like every 2 and 1 half
hours and she was it was it was 2 and 1
half to 3 hours and then she'd
breastfeed for an hour and I was too t
TI to like move her to a crib I was like
it'll be easier if she's right next to
me seems like the more natural thing to
do I'm going to co
sleep I am not going to be doing that
again because I didn't sleep for like a
year she didn't learn how to sleep
through the
night because she was with me and could
just like reach over for the boob
whenever so obviously she's not going to
sleep through the night no I'm not going
to go sleep I need to sleep or I won't
be able to function and I don't like not
being able to function so I'm not doing
that again and that's part of the reason
why I'm hiring a newborn care specialist
to help with the nights uh for the first
three
months and then last
question yeah what are your plans for
postpartum rest I have my own business
and planning Matt leave is
hard I'm having a really hard time with
this I know that I'm going to
be very sleep deprived for the first
month at minimum Plus recovering from
child birth which is a real real
physical
recovery uh
so what's my plan I don't have a very
wellth thought out plan other than
really identifying the important goals
that I want to hit and only focusing on
those and trying to not to get bog down
by the little things because the little
things can be pushed off so I've
separated out the companies and I have
my like I'm doing so many way too many
things to had a baby and we moved into a
new house that's been under construction
for 6 months longer than it should have
been which is a whole another
thing and then I have like my brand my
dad's
brand to manage my podcast to do the
Fuller Health supplements these guys
which I'm looking forward to so I can't
enjoy these bad boys but you can and
it'll save you if you drink over the
holidays even once it's after party The
Hangover pill I launched poorly timed
really because after we were done
testing I got pregnant but if you
haven't tried it it works insanely well
to reduce the feelings of a hangover we
have a 30-day money back guarantee I
would order it now to get it in time for
Christmas although shipping is really
fast I think we have two days shipping
so you'll be okay but order now anyway
get it for New Year's and the holidays
and Christmas go to Fuller health.com
code MP for 15% off and you guys can
enjoy the holidays in a way I cannot
enjoy the rest of this episode um and
Peterson Academy and
it's too many things for somebody who
isn't pregnant I finally hit what I
understand as too many things at the
same
time so yeah like I said I've just tried
identif exactly what goals I need to
focus on and move everything else to the
side for the
first four to six weeks and then I'm
hoping I'm going to be at like I work
from home so I'll be able to breastfeed
I'm going to have help so that they can
watch the baby but then I can breastfeed
I can hang out with baby but I can like
plan meetings and do work when the
baby's sleeping and when someone else is
entertaining the
baby so I kind of just plan on doing
both but definitely slowing things down
for the first four weeks because I need
to recover need to focus on having the
baby and that's what's important I guess
the last thing I could cover are what
are the pregnancy symptoms for people
who haven't been pregnant
and for me it was mainly a meat
aversion um I can't get comfortable I
haven't been comfortable in like 2
months I'm waking up twice at night to
pee cuz the baby is sitting on my
bladder I'm sleeping with a pillow under
my legs or between my legs on my side
one behind my back one under my stomach
and a heating pad I'm also sitting
elevated because my nose is so congested
this pregnancy I've spent 6 months maybe
breathing through my mouth and that's
partly because my allergies have
skyrocketed during the pregnancy I moved
to Arizona where it's dusty I have a
dust allergy it's like I'm going to be
allergic wherever I am but I've had to
sleep sitting up as well uh what else
are the symptoms and
then most of the symptoms I have are
emotional I'm more volatile I'm angrier
and I haven't had the positive dopamine
emotion
in I don't know six months which is
really like I'm okay on the podcast
right now when I'm talking to you guys
about it but like it's not fun I'm
really looking forward to January 7th
and feeling more like me um because it's
hard on my mood
so those were my main pregnancy symptoms
they're much better than they were when
I had that miscarriage it was much worse
and with Scarlet it was much
worse and this is much better and I'm
really grateful for that but this isn't
great uh mood-wise
it's also frustrating to like get
invited to things and have to not go cuz
my body can't handle it even though my
brain really wants to so I didn't go to
Dad's Ark convention in London because I
was like I'm in Arizona it's something
like a 9h hour time difference to London
I think it was at that point anyway and
I was like I'm not going to be able to
do it I was about 30 weeks pregnant to
that point I was like it's just going to
kill me I'm going to be miserable so I'm
missing things and
excited for this portion to be over I'm
very excited to have the baby and the
suffering right now is worth having the
baby uh for the next month I'm going to
be
doing one or two more interviews and
maybe my body's kind of been like you're
done Michaela just lay down stop doing
stuff but I have one more interview plan
that I really want to do and then I'm
going to do I think a podcast with my
mom a podcast with my dad probably a
podcast with both my mom and my dad
because they've come to stay with us for
the next month they're trying the mold
treatment
and yeah and just kind of try and take
it easy attempt to calm myself down for
the next month so thanks for listening
good luck to any other pregnant women
out there
and having a baby is totally worth it
having there's nothing like having a
kid and I do believe like I don't
believe that you have to be the Trad Mom
I hate that fad if you want to stay home
that's am amazing do that it's a
full-time job like calling it a
stay-at-home
mom doesn't Encompass the like six jobs
that you actually have as a stay-at-home
mom so if you're able to do that and it
fulfills you Kudos I think that would be
that would be nice but I'm
too I don't know addicted to dopamine or
something to be able to to do that
without getting resentful and feeling
like I'm missing out on accomplishing
goals whatever that
means
so either way whether you're the type of
person and I don't mean to like insult
tra traditional women because that's not
what I mean at all good for them
seriously I'm more annoyed at the people
talking down to women if they're not
doing the traditional female role that
are kind of in the red pilled weird
area uh that sickens me um but I think
there's a way to figure out your life so
that you
can attempt to do both I don't think
doing both is easy like you do miss out
on you know if you're going to go to
work you're going to miss out on part of
your kids
life so you have to balance it's a
balancing act as a female and it's hard
so good luck to all the women out there
and I will talk to you guys
[Music]
soon